hello ladies and gentlemen from hamburg
in these very special and challenging
times
we hope you're all doing well and
welcome you to today's live broadcast
on how to get the best out of your
cell-based essays
our webinar will be presented to you by
my lovely colleague dr jessica wagner
and by dr eric bonk from our corporation
partner promega
both presenters are application
specialists focusing on
cell handling and their respective
companies and i will give you a short
introduction
about both in a minute my name is
christian harverland marketing manager
for instruments and systems at appendoff
and i will be your moderator for today's
webinar
at the end of the presentation i would
like to give you a quick overview about
solutions that might be helpful for you
to improve your daily cell culture work
now a little bit of technical
information
that is necessary for this uh webinar
before we begin i would like to
encourage you all to get the most out of
the
this webinar by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
just simply type them into the ask a
question box on the left
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of this webinar
if you have any trouble to see or hear
the presentation click on the support
tab
at the top right or report your problem
by clicking on the
ask a question box on the left and we
will help you
continuing education credits can be
obtained by clicking on the tab at the
top right
and just following the process
just one comment if you want to stay
updated on all
upcoming cell culture webinars just
simply click on the inside cell culture
tab that you can see
on the top and just type in your name
and your email address to receive a
monthly newsletter that is dedicated to
cell culture experts with helpful videos
posters tips and tricks for your daily
work
and more and you can also find an
example of the newsletter
on the registration page now let me
shortly introduce a presentation of your
webinar today
dr jessica wagner from eppendorf and dr
eric bong from promega both hold a phd
in biology with a focus
on and many years of practical and
theoretical experience in cell culture
both are amongst the most experienced
application specialists focusing on cell
handling in their respective companies
and frequently share the knowledge in
workshops and seminars
around the world you can find a complete
biography of both speakers by just
clicking the biography tab
at the top today we are happy that
jessica and eric are going to share
their knowledge with us
so enough of the talking from my side
let's get started
jessica and eric the stage is yours
thank you christian for the introduction
and welcome everyone also from my side
and thank you for joining our webinar
today
um i want to start with
looking at the contents of today's
presentation
first i will talk about the general
aspects of cell culture routine and how
to increase reproducibility of your data
when preparing the cells for an essay
and then eric will take over the next
part and go into detail about optimizing
essay setups
in the end i will touch the topic of how
to avoid cryptic contamination that can
influence your essay results
here is an overview of the cell culture
workflow so
independent of the specific cell type
you're working with
these steps are part of the lab routine
for this webinar appendoff and promega
are joining forces to support you in
optimizing your cell-based assay results
we will cover the general aspects like
optimal seating techniques and
cultivation conditions
and go into the details of different
modes of detection and essay setup
but before we proceed here comes our
first survey
[Music]
i'm interested in the cell types that
you are working with
so please select all that applies so
what kind of cell types are you using
continuous cell lines
stem cells or other primary cells
we will work wait a couple of seconds
um and wait until the answers are coming
in
so i will read the question again what
kind of cells are you using continuous
cell lines
stem cells or other primary cells
okay and i can see the votes are coming
in right now
i think we will wait a second more until
we share the results with you
okay so i think we can close the poll
now
and share the results
so i hope that you can all see the
columns now so
we see that the majority of you is
working with continuous cell lines
almost 80 percent
18 percent of you is working with stem
cells
and about 45 of you is working with
other primary cells
okay so thank you for participating
um so no matter which cell types you are
working with there are some aspects that
can be considered to increase
the reproducibility and consistency of
your cell-based essays
and this is what we are looking at in
the next chapter
so let's have a closer look at this
first experimental step that is so
important
the seeding of cells the precondition
for getting comparable results in an
essay
is to seed out the same number of cells
for every negative control positive
control
and for every experimental replicate of
course variations in seeding cell
numbers and the formation of air bubbles
during seeding
will not only increase standard
deviations it will also make your
results less reliable
when you fill for instance a multi-well
plate with cells it will take sometimes
until you have filled all the wells
the longer the seeding process the
higher is the variation in cell number
from one well to the other
as you can see in the image on the upper
right the cells sink towards the bottom
of the tube
with time and this sedimentation goes
quite fast within minutes
therefore you need to resuspend or mix
the cells to swirl them up in between to
get an equal number of cells in every
well
saying that we should keep in mind that
cell culture media tend to foam due to
the high protein content of supplemented
serum
air bubbles can hinder cell attachment
in the lower image here
you can see how an air bubble hinders
the cells nearby to adhere properly to
the
substrate so you should avoid harsh and
fast pipetting to reduce the formation
of air bubbles and also to reduce the
shear forces
which further stress the cells in fact
there are a lot of aspects about
pipetting that are often underestimated
pipetting can have a big impact on fair
culture experiments
not only the type of liquid influences
the pipetting result also the pipetting
technique plays a role
so when aspirating the liquid hold the
pipet vertical as seen here on the left
image
and immerse the tip only slightly and
try to keep a constant immersion depth
if you follow this technique you will
improve the precision of the volume that
you are pipetting
now let's have a closer look on how
pipetting can affect a cell-based essay
in this graph here you see the results
of a cell viability essay
each column represents one row of a 96
well plates
the aim was to seed an identical number
of cells in each well
two rows were left out for blanks the
cells were seeded with a
manual a channel pipette from a
reservoir and after 24 hours the number
of viable cells was determined using a
colorimetric essay
in rows one to five you see varying cell
numbers in the wells and high standard
deviations
here the user did not mix the cell
suspension between pipetting each row
so the cell sedimented in the reservoir
with time
and in addition the pipette was held in
different angles and heights during
aspiration
in rows 6 to 10 you see the results with
mixing the remaining cells before
pipetting each row
aspirating at constant height and in
upper right position
taken together these data show that the
pipetting technique has a big influence
on the results of an essay
besides the technique the other thing
that can affect results of an essay are
the so called
plate position effects if you work with
a 96 well plate the usual volume you use
is 100 to 200 microliters per well
especially during longer incubation
periods evaporation can become
a critical factor with a small volume
especially in the outer
wells this is a phenomenon that we call
the edge effect
so the outer wells of the plates should
not be used for analysis because the
evaporation can lead to different
cellular responses
in the co2 incubator the conditions for
the cells should be as stable as
possible during incubation
every time the door of the incubator is
open the atmosphere inside is disturbed
it is a good advice to reduce the
traffic in and out of the incubator as
much as possible
only open the door when necessary and
close it as soon as possible
some incubators show temperature
overshoots to reduce the recovery time
after a door opening
this can harm the cells so your
incubator should have a quick recovery
of co2 and especially temperature
without any overshoot as seen here on
the upper right
graph especially when you work with very
sensitive cells or when you work in a
lab where many people are sharing an
incubator
it can be a good idea to have an
incubator with segmented inner doors
like you see it here on the lower right
picture
the small opening area helps to keep the
atmosphere inside stable
in some cases it can be a good idea to
even have separate incubators for
maintenance cultures
and running experiments so you seed the
cells for an essay
do the treatment manipulation or
whatever you want to do
and put the cells into a separate
incubator for the time of the
experiment your colleague who has to
split the cells or change the medium
uses the other incubator and thus your
experiment is not
disturbed so much by fluctuations of the
inner atmosphere
temperature may be the most critical
parameter in an incubator because
deviations from the optimal temperature
can be harmful for the cells
here on the right you see results of it
no
sorry on the left you see the results of
a temperature measurement in different
incubators according to a dean standard
27 different spots were measured inside
the incubators and as you see
some devices show quite high deviations
from the optimum
as indicated here by the darker blue and
red dots
shown on the right image is an example
of how cells can react to non-optimal
temperature
in this case we incubated human
pluripotent stem cells at
30 37 and 38 degrees and you can see
that the one degree difference results
in quite obvious change in morphology of
the cell type
this stress situation might not be so
obvious for every cell type but
but as you can imagine even less obvious
cellular responses can influence your
assay results
monitoring cultivation parameters and
documenting performance of your
incubator are measures to establish
long-term reproducibility of the
experiments in your lab
here on the lower right you see a
screenshot of the menu of the eppendorf
cell expert co2 incubator
the red arrow indicates a door opening
and you see that the curves of co2 and
temperature are dropping
you can simply check for door openings
or track back the performance data to
see what might have influenced your
essay this time so before you start
troubleshooting the essay itself it
might be worth looking into the
performance of your incubator
another stress factor for cells are
vibrations here are two simple examples
on the left you see cells
[Music]
that are suffering from frequent door
openings
and these door openings cause uneven
adhesion of the cells to the substrate
they are growing on
on the right it is shown
what happens when you move vessels with
freshly seeded cells so for example you
want to put your petri dishes into a
crowded incubator and need to push other
vessels aside to make space on the shelf
this manual moving can disturb even cell
adhesion
and distribution
external vibration sources in the lab
include include
running centrifuges fridges or air
condition
some incubators have a fan inside which
is obviously one of the most critical
sources of vibration
because the cells are placed more or
less directly next to the fan
so whenever possible incubators without
internal fan
should be preferred especially for
sensitive cells or sensitive experiments
let's have a closer look at the cells in
culture so no matter what you do with
the cell culture it is important
to determine the right time point for a
particular cell type
in this graphic here you see a typical
growth curve of cells and culture
it is important to not let the cells
overgrow until they are in their
stationary phase and do not
proliferate anymore the optimal time
point is when the cells are in their
exponential growth phase also called log
phase and this is when they are between
70 and 80
confluent a growth curve provides
information about behavior
of a certain cell type during
cultivation and thus facilitates the
assessment
whether any biological response can be
attributed to the effect of a tested
factor
or whether it may reflect an imbalance
within the cell culture system
it has often been described that the
passage number influences cellular
behavior
the passage number is a record of the
number of times the cell culture has
been sub-cultivated
there are numerous studies given
evidence that the passage number affects
the cell line's characteristics over
time
it has been described that cell lines at
high passage numbers experience
alteration
in morphology response to stimuli growth
rates protein expression
transfection efficiency and more so
looking at all these passage number
effects
in different cell types described in the
literature the basic question one can
think of is
how many passages are too many and
before we go on with the presentation i
want to
hand over this question to you and start
our next survey
what do you think how many passages can
a cell line be cultured for
so the answers you can click on are not
more than 20 passages
20 to 60 passages up to 100 passages
or the passage number has no influence
on this
on the cells so what do you think how
many passages can a saline be cultured
for
not more than 20 20 to 60
up to 100 passages or the passage number
has no influence on the cells
and again i will wait a couple of
seconds and give you time to answer
so i see the answers are slowly coming
in the columns are still changing so i
wait a couple of seconds more
okay and um i think we can share now the
results with you thank you for answering
okay i hope you see the results now so
um
around 60 percent says
more than 20 passages around 34
says 20 to 60 passages is okay
only five percent uses their cells up to
100 passages
and only one percent
says the passage number has no influence
on the cells okay
so thank you again for participating i
will go
back to the presentation
all right so in general we can say
keep the passage number as low as
possible continuous cell lines like
cancer cell lines basically have an
unlimited lifespan
but although they can particularly
proliferate indefinitely
their genotype and phenotype can change
over time
a lot of the well-established and
well-characterized cell lines that are
used in laboratories worldwide have been
isolated from their original tissues
decades ago
when you work with such an old
continuous cell line it is most likely
not possible to obtain
up to obtain early passages from the
cell line though
but you have to set a starting point as
a reference to be able to obtain
reliable results with this cell line
first of all the starting point should
be cells of high quality
the best way to ensure this high quality
is obtaining cells from
established cell banks here you get well
documented authenticated cell lines
which serve as the best reference
culture for your experiments
by establishing a reference sales doc
you have a constant supply of early
passages from your cell lines
now you can determine the safe passage
number for that particular cell line of
interest
by establishing certain baselines for
example and test the cells for the
presence and expression level of a
certain protein
monitoring the proliferation rate over
time and keep an eye on any changes in
cellular morphology
by getting to know yourself you will get
an idea of whether and how the
cells change in relation to prolonged
passaging
and maybe very simple advice do not keep
cells in culture
that are not actively used for
experiments so
don't passage continuously but rather
establish new cells from frozen stock if
required
and now i would like to hand over to
eric from promega who will go into
detail about optimizing the setup of
your cell-based essay
thank you jessica and thanks everyone
for joining this webinar
so now that we've learned a lot about
how to ideally handle cells
in this next section of the webinar i
would like to focus
on how to use these cells in an
experimental setting a so-called
cell-based assay
and primarily i'd like to touch on
different key factors known to
significantly contribute to the outcome
of such an essay
i will start by introducing the various
detection modes available and highlight
their principles and features
and then also related to this i'd like
to spend some time talking about how to
choose the appropriate microtiter plate
we will then continue to talk about how
the actual design of an assay
the cells themselves as well as the
readout so the
marker that you choose to determine with
your essay
and finally also the assay timing can
affect your data
so let's have a brief look at the
different detection modes available
the first option you have is an
absorbance-based assay
here you have an external light source
that sends
light through a sample and what you
basically determine is a decrease in
light intensity
due to partial absorbance of light by
components within the sample
in general one can state that these are
the least sensitive
assays they suffer from a low signal to
background ratio and a low dynamic range
these parameters are kind of improved in
the second option you have a
fluorescence-based assay
here again we have an external light
source that
generates light of a distinct wavelength
and this light excites the fluorophore
within the sample and what you determine
is the emission of light at a longer
wavelength
what i would like to convey is that you
will always yield the highest
sensitivity with the third option the
bioluminescence-based assay
here you have a signal generated
directly within your sample in a
continuously occurring chemical reaction
so there is no need for that external
light source
and this is associated with a
considerably lower background
as when you compare it for example to a
fluorescence-based approach
where background can make up a large
portion of your signal
due to a phenomenon known as
autofluorescence
although at the first glance the
absorbance-based assays
appear to be the least expensive ones a
major drawback is that usually they are
not compatible with multiplexing
however a fluorescence and a
bioluminescence based assay can be
ideally combined in such a multiplexing
approach
multiplexing means that you determine
two different parameters using one and
the same
sample so in other words you
sequentially run
two essays on the same sample
in order to do this of course these
assays have to fulfill certain
requirements they need to be
biologically and chemically compatible
and also they need to generate signals
that you can easily distinguish
and last but not least the higher end
volume must fit
with the microtiter plate format you use
multiplexing is associated with several
advantages
first of all you have these two data
sets generated with the same sample
so this also means that you maintain the
same variables
but also if you think of cost this
approach
is beneficial because you can save
sample material and also your
consumables
but probably the most important benefit
is that you can very easily
normalize your data and you can also
verify it because you have these two
separate data sets that can support each
other
no matter what detection mode you choose
it is absolutely crucial to pick the
appropriate microtiter plate
for any cell-based acid you would want
that plate to be a sterile plate
and it should have a lid if you work
with adherent cells it should also be tc
or tissue culture treated
you can then choose from clear black and
white plates the black and white ones
are also available in different
formats a solid and a clear bottom
format
the clear button format has the obvious
advantage that you can
look at yourself through the microscope
the disadvantage however is yet that you
will lose
signal to some extent you have a higher
welterwell crosstalk
and also this format appears to be more
expensive
for an absorbs-based acid you would go
for the clear plate
and depending on what region of the
spectrum you're interested
in you can choose from different
materials
the most important thing is that you
must never
use that clear plate for a
luminescence-based assay
and i think that's conceivable if you
think of that continuous light
production that goes on in the wells of
your plate
and in a clear plate that light could go
sheerly anywhere
so you could not track it down to a
distinct will
the primary choice for a fluorescence
based assay
is the black plate here a black pigment
is added to the plastic in order to
decrease the autofluorescence of the
plastic
so the background caused by the plate
itself
and finally the primary choice for a
luminescence based assay is the white
plate
here a brightener is added to the
plastic which
improves the reflective properties of
these plates
so a maximum of your signal will
actually be reflected towards the
detector
and also in a luminescence-based assay
setup
this decreases the well-to-well
crosstalk
if you work with white plates you should
be familiar with
phosphorescence because white plates can
absorb
and re-emit photons and this is why we
generally
recommend you to store these plates in a
dark space
and if you pipet them to do this in a
dimmed atmosphere
or if you insert them into your plate
reader
leave them until you perform your
measurements for
a few minutes because that dark
incubation allows the phosphorescent
signal to disappear
what i also would like to highlight is
that there are different qualities when
it comes to microtiter plates
and this we showed you by a very simple
experiment
where we use two 96 well plates two
white plates from two different
vendors and what we did is we performed
the serial dilution of the luciferase in
the first column of the plate
the rest of the plate was filled with
pbs
what you can nicely see is that in plate
a the signal generated within that first
column of the plate
almost travels all the way through the
plate while in plate b
it is mainly restricted to the side of
its origin
and also the absolute signal intensities
appear to be more higher for plate b
than for plate a so this suggests that
the reflective properties of plate b
are higher presumably because a higher
amount of that brightener has been added
during the manufacturing process
in any case plate b has the properties
that you would want applied to have so a
high signal
output and a low crosstalk
whenever you set up the cell-based essay
yourself
you should always try to minimize the
total number of steps required to
perform the essay
because every step is a potential source
of
error and can increase the variability
of your data
and this is exactly why promega assays
follow this common principle the
so-called admix and measure principle
this means we always have a single
reagent that we only need to add to the
cells we briefly mix
and then we can read our signal we also
say our assays are homogeneous
because we only have these addition
steps and there is no further sample
processing
such as washing off cells or removal of
supernatants required
and this is also what makes these assays
hds compatible and also what makes them
easy to automate
but the fewer pipetting steps also make
it easier for the scientists to actually
perform the essays
and that makes them also time saving
and last but not least as i already
mentioned this
very much improves the quality of your
data
a nice example where we took the
streamlining of an assay workflow to
extremes are the so-called
lumid immunoassays this is probably one
of the newest promega technologies
and it is a technology that serves as an
alternative to common immunoassays such
as the traditional elisa approach
i'm pretty sure everyone survey is
familiar with a conventional
elisa workflow as it is depicted here
we have a very heterogeneous multi-step
process
that involves all these tedious washing
and incubation steps and which
can take you up to two days in time
with the lumid immunoassays we were able
to eliminate the majority of these steps
so we for example remove the coating and
the blocking steps
because we work in solution we remove
the washing steps
and we combined the separate antibody
addition steps into a single edition
step
so by very much streamlining that
procedure we could
eliminate a number of variability
sources
and the nice benefit is that also these
assays can be
easier accomplished and faster
accomplished and
it only takes 60 to 90 minutes
another important factor associated with
variability of data that is directly
related to your experimental layout or
assay design is the so-called edge
effect that we've already heard of
and which mainly affects the outer wells
of such a microtiter plate
and it is actually an effect that is
apparent at two different
levels first of all we have a higher
evaporation in the outer worlds than in
the inner wells
and this leads to a concentration of
salts and solutes within your medium
and this concentration can alter the
growth and the viability of your cells
so what you actually end up with is a
gradient
of cell number across your plate
a good way to tackle this problem is to
either use
specialized plates such as ependorf
offers which have
a mode around the outer wells that you
can fill with
liquid to insulate these wells or
if these are not available you can also
fill the outer wells of such a plate as
well as maybe also the interval spaces
with pre-equilibrated sterile liquid
the downside of course is that this
decreases the number of samples that you
can
essay per plate
second level that this effect becomes
apparent on is a temperature effect
because you can imagine that the outer
wells
will respond more sensitive towards
changes in temperature than the inner
wells
the scenario where we see changes in
temperature
frequently is the shuttling of the plate
between the incubator and the reading
instrument so it is advisable to
hurry up when you need to shuttle or to
avoid shuttling by leaving the plate in
the reading instrument
and by using this instrument as an
incubator
in any case you should pre-equilibrate
all the reagent
as well as the reading instrument to the
temperature that you actually would like
to run the measurement
at
also important for the reproducibility
of your data is the seeding density of
your cells
and while it is pretty conceivable that
if you seed cells at different densities
in microtiter plates and if you treat
them with a given dose of the cytotoxic
compound that these cells behave
differently it is not as obvious that
also the seeding density in your stock
culture flask can
affect the outcome of your experiment
and this is shown in this experiment
where we seeded cells
in stock culture flasks at different
densities low medium and high
we harvested these cells and we seeded
them at an equal density
in a microtiter plate the cells were
then
treated with a cytotoxic compound and
two parameters
atp content and cafe 37 activation were
determined
what you can nicely see is that there is
a clear difference in how these cells
respond towards the treatment with
windblastin
and in fact the cells derived from the
low density stock culture flask
appear to respond more sensitive than
the others
so this is why it is really advisable to
agree on different standard operating
procedures in your cell culture lab
so that you make sure to always work
with fixed
time points when you harvest or seed
cells or
fixed cell numbers simply to reduce the
risk for this variability source
another variability source also directly
related to your cells is their metabolic
states
in these experiments here we assay
different metabolic parameters using our
energy metabolism assays
and here you can see the consumption of
glucose and glutamine which are the two
substrate most
commonly added to cell culture media
what you see is that within a time frame
of
two days these substrates are mainly
completely consumed
and of course at that time when
substrates become
limiting the cells need to adapt they
will undergo a metabolic switch in order
to stay alive
and it is conceivable that these cells
might behave differently in an assay
than
cells exposed to excess substrate
going along with the decline in the
substrate levels is a buildup of
metabolic products such as lactate and
glutamate
and the buildup of lactate is what you
can visually
easily recognize by a change of the
medium color from red
to yellow and this acidification of
media is a clear stress factor to your
cells
and it can change their cell growth but
also
their the viability of the cells so it
might be a bad idea to culture your
cells over the weekend
and on monday if you discover a flask
like this to use these cells for an
essay
but also a shift in ph in the other
direction in the basic region can be
problematic
and this happens frequently if you use a
bicarbonate buffered media which most
media are
and you leave your media bottle in an
open state under the bench for a while
because then due to the low atmospheric
co2 your media will turn
basic it will turn pink if you add that
to yourself it can have the same
consequence
so you see the viability is a really key
factor
for data reproducibility and you should
establish a cell culture routine that
maintains a high viable cell culture
cell viability assays can aid you in
doing so
they can help you to compare for example
different
media compositions fcs batches
or you can determine the effect of
different centrifugation
times and forces or trypsinization times
common biomarkers for viability are
the reduction equivalents such as nadh
atp content and also dna content which
changes upon division of cells
then people look at membrane potential
or they determine the activity of
certain enzymes
instead of measuring viability you can
also measure cytotoxicity
common markers for cytotoxicity are
a loss of membrane integrity and the
therewith associated release of
cytosolic factors such as lactate
dehydrogenase
people measure the activity of certain
proteases
or changes in membrane composition and
finally
also a decline in atp and nadh content
is indicative for a cytotoxic
event importantly depending on what
marker you choose you can then
also make a statement on the mechanism
that your cells have died from
our gold standard assay for cell
viability is the so-called cell tita
glow assay
this is a bioluminescent lytic endpoint
assay that quantifies the amount of atp
within your sample
and it also sticks to this at mix and
measure principle so we have a single
reagent containing all the required
components
in this case it contains all the
components of the firefly luciferase
reaction
except for a crucial cofactor atp
this atp is provided by the sample
which are the cells and which are lies
by
the buffer of the cell tata glow assay
so this released atp then drives the
firefly luciferase reaction so that the
light output and the amount of
atp can be correlated and you can
thereby conclude on the viability of
your cells
an example for a cytotoxicity assay is
the ldh glow assay
this assay indirectly determines the
release
or the loss of membrane integrity by
determination of the amount of
ldh released into the cell culture
supernatant
and it does this by coupling the ldh
reaction so the
oxidation of lactate to pyruvate to
another enzymatic reaction which
converts
a pro substrate into the firefly
luciferase substrate luciferin
so in the end light output and the
amount of ldh
correlate
this assay is a non-lytic assay and
its bioluminescent nature makes it
highly sensitive
and this is why you can use that assay
also in a kinetic fashion
only tiny amounts of sample are required
usually two to five microliters of the
supernatant
which means you can collect sample at
different time points
and you then have the option to either
essay them directly or you collect
all the samples and essay them together
here's some representative data
generated using that assay
this is with skbr3 cells that's a human
hair to positive
breast carcinoma cell line that was
treated with an antibody
drug conjugate and you nicely see the
dose and time dependent increase in the
luminescent signal
whenever you run an ldh release assay
you should always use heat inactivated
fcs
because the fcs is a considerable source
of ldh
and you would thereby decrease the
sensitivity of your assay by increasing
the background
what you also should be always aware of
is the fact that every cytotoxicity
marker has its own time dependent
profile when it
appears and disappears and there are
also markers which are really specific
for a certain type of cell death
for example while you can measure a case
caspase activation in apoptosis
you couldn't do this in necrotic cells
or if we look at the release of ldh this
is an
early event in necrotic cells but rather
a very late event in apoptotic cells
actually when these cells turn secondary
necrotic
or the decline in atp levels occurs
rapidly in necrosis but more modestly in
apoptotic
cells so you see the timing of your
assay is really another
important factor that you may want to
consider and this is further illustrated
by that
experiment where we treated cells with a
cytotoxic compound
and we assayed three different
parameters
by ability through atp we determined the
activity of a so-called debt cell
protease to estimate cytotoxicity and
then also caspase activation
at an early time point we see as
expected a decrease in viability that is
accompanied by an increase in
cytotoxicity in caspase activation
however the same experiment measured at
a later time point
in fact indicates a decrease in
cytotoxicity in caspase activation
and this is exactly the problem that you
may run into when using
an endpoint assay and an activity-based
biomarker such as an enzyme
because these biomarkers can undergo
degradation or inactivation processes
and you could simply miss the time point
that you actually would like to look at
a good way to approach this is to use
real-time measurements because then you
can cover
a larger time frame and you can easily
identify the time point that you may
want to
investigate further with for example an
endpoint assay in the future
i would like to give you two examples
for such a real-time assay
one is the celtox green cytotoxicity
assay this
assay is based on a fluorescent dna
binding dye that is cell impermeable
so it's excluded from viable cells
however once these cells
lose their membrane integrity it binds
to dna and yields a fluorescent signal
this assay supports
the real-time course analysis up to 72
hours so you could
cover a time frame of three days and
also
you can nicely multiplex that assay with
our bioluminescent
assay portfolio if you don't want to run
a cytotox assay but rather a viability
essay in the real-time mode
the real-time glow empty cell viability
assay is a good option
this assay is based on a purified
luciferase that you would
add to your cell culture supernatant
along with a pro
substrate of that luciferase in viable
cells
this pro substrate gets converted to the
substrate
a process that does not occur in dead
cells
so only viable cells will yield a
luminescent signal
similar to the cell talk screen essay
also this assay supports these real-time
course analysis up to 72 hours
it is multiplexing compatible and
another advantage is that you can use
the sample for downstream processing you
so you could for example isolate rna and
run a real-time pcr
beside the simplicity to identify
correct time points with real-time
assays they also have an advantage
with regard to assay cost
costs and this is exemplified here so if
we think
of a real-time course analysis with a
time point or data point recorded
every hour which means 72 data points
an endpoint assay would require us to
use 72
microtiter plates and 72 times
medium cells and reagents and you can
actually gather
the same amount of data with a single
plate
single times medium cells and reagents
using a real-time assay
and with this i'd like to hand over back
to jessica who's going to tell you a
little bit more about avoiding cryptic
contamination
thank you eric um
okay so there are so we just have to
change the slide here you go
there are two types of contamination i
would like to talk about here because
both are not so easy to detect and can
have
dramatic effects on your assays or any
cell-based experiments that you perform
the first one is microplasma a special
type of bacteria
which is too small to be seen in a
standard bright field microscope
they don't cause any turbidity or color
change of the culture medium like other
bacteria do
and are therefore often overlooked the
other type of contamination that often
goes undetected
are the so-called eukaryotic
contaminations these are
cross-contaminated or even misidentified
cell lines
there are estimation that 15 to 20 of
all cell lines used worldwide are either
cross-contaminated or even misidentified
i want to go a little bit deeper into
the topic of how microplasma affects
cellular metabolism by showing you some
data from a study published in 2013.
in this study hela cells were infected
with microplasma followed by analysis of
the
differential gene regulation up on
different time points of infection
as you can see in this graph the number
of genes
that respond to the microplasma
infection increases dramatically with
time
and this is just an extract of the list
of genes that
were deregulated upon infection
let's come to the eukaryotic
contaminations cross-contaminations of
different cell lines usually result from
accidents somewhere during the handling
of cells so it is basically a mistake in
aseptic handling
mislabeling of samples and inconsistent
nomenclature of cell lines also
contribute to this phenomenon
as soon as two cell types are mixed up
it is very hard to distinguish them
this process goes fast and it might go
undetected especially if the morphology
of the cells is not drastically
different
but although the phenomenon of
cross-contaminated and misidentified
cell lines has been recognized for half
a century
as i mentioned before still to date we
know that 15 to 20 percent of all cell
lines
used are either cross-contaminated or
misidentified
i want to show you two examples of cell
lines to give you an idea of the
scientific as well as the financial
implications once misidentified cell
lines are used for studies
due to a contamination in the 1960s both
of these cell lines are
now known to be composed of hela cells
meaning scientists who thought
they were working on hab2 and in 407
were in fact likely experimenting on
healer cells it was calculated that over
700 million dollars has been spent
on published work involving just these
two contaminated cell lines
and the amount of money spent on
subsequent work based on those papers is
even much higher and these are just two
examples that show you how
that cell line authentication is a
crucial thing
um okay so before we start with our q a
session i hand over to christian again
yeah thank you jessica thank you eric
for this great presentation i've
recognized that we have a lot of people
joining us today live
so i guess there will be a lot of
question for our q a session but
before we will start with the last poll
question and the q a session
i promised you in the beginning that you
will get a quick insight into some
helpful solutions for your daily work
and i
will show you in a second um so here are
some uh
product solutions that you might not be
aware of
um from eppendorf the first one is our
co2 incubator family
cell expert that has been launched quite
um
about a year ago and that might be
interesting for you
so this is what it looks like and i
would just highlight some of the
the main benefits here so it's very easy
to clean
if you look inside the chamber there's
no fan
there's a deep drawn chamber inside and
one of the things that we've
taken care of is a very high temperature
homogeneity inside the incubator
so we measured at 27 spots inside the
incubator the temperature homogeneity so
it doesn't really matter where you
put your um your cell culture vessels
inside the incubator you
always the cells always experience the
same
cell culture conditions um one thing
that is also
important in modern cell culture labs
especially for
instruments that are running 24 7
are the running costs or costs that are
related to
um to to internal parts that have
been have to be exchanged
over time or especially gas consumption
which is a real
important topic and if you're interested
in this on
uh how you can save money with the co2
incubators you can see on the left side
of your screen
if you go to the resources section you
find a paper on cost of ownership for
cto incubators and also
a paper on or a little flyer on how the
co2 incubator cell expert can help you
to
optimize your cell-based essay
all right one thing that's also new um
is uh
are the 25 ml conical tubes that we
offer which you can see here
um it's especially useful for improving
uh contamination prevention in the cell
culture lab because you all know
that if you don't have steady hands on
uh on monday morning
it's really hard to pipe that into 15 ml
or 50 ml conicals without touching the
the rim or the the rim of the of the
vessels inside
so it helps you a lot if you have those
uh those tiny 25 ml tubes to to prevent
the contamination
if you want to learn more and if you
want to request a free sample
just go to eppendorf.com 25 ml
one last thing i've mentioned before is
our newsletter inside cell culture it's
called
if you want to get regular information
for cell culture
professionals you get tips and tricks
for your daily work videos downloads
posters and more you also get
access to advanced educational webinars
and also if you want to stay updated
upcoming webinars
just sign in go to eppendorf.com icc
and just type in your name and your
email address and you're ready
to go all right
so go one slide
further if you um so let's come to the
last port question here
um so we can improve our webinars for
you
so the question is how do you rate the
content of today's
webinar we highly appreciate your
feedback here
and we go directly to the live q a
section of this webinar so if you have
any
question that you would like to ask eric
or jessica
please do so now just click on the ask
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we will answer as many of the
questions as we have time for
so let's get started just
choose a question let's have a look at
this
so one question that we have is
um
let's see i think this one will be good
for jessica we use a multi pad
uh not a multi-channel pipette for
seedling cells do you have any tips for
using that
to get the same amount of cells in wells
jessica this one what do you think uh
good question
um yeah so we um we checked different
let's say pipetting tools and how they
how they can be used for seeding cells
and with a multi-pad which is basically
a dispenser
there is no need to resuspend or to
swirl the cells up in between as long as
you're fast enough so you can be very
fast with pipetting or with
with a with a dispenser um
and seeding out cells and therefore you
don't need to mix the cells
like you like you would do with a
multi-channel pipette
and a reagent reservoir or even a single
channel pipette and the
the cell suspension in the tube so with
a dispenser of course it needs a little
bit of practice
uh with the handling but um with the
dispenser you can easily
fill a 96 well plate completely um and
have an equal number of
of cells in each well yeah thank you
very much
um let's move on there's um an
interesting one that's probably uh
directed towards eric uh regarding
the toxicity markers and the question is
regarding the ldh release how long can i
store the aliquots from the cell culture
supernatant
eric yeah thank you for that question
um here it is important that you
dilute your sample in a storage buffer
that is mentioned
in the the technical manual before you
freeze them
because this buffer helps to preserve
the activity of ldh
what we've tested so far is to store
samples up to one month at -20
and we did not note any decrease in the
activity of ldh
or any change in the ec50 values of
compounds that we treated the cells with
and i can imagine that probably also you
can store them for longer times but
the the one month is the time frame that
we've tested
oh thank you very much so we're there a
lot of questions coming in wow
um let's choose another one so this
sounds also interesting and the question
is
how long does it take for cells to
sediment in a reagent reservoir after
mixing the cell suspension one minute
less is that the time available for
seeding a plate before mixing in
and the question is how do you mix a
cell suspension in a reagent reservoir
type heading up and down shaking in an
eight formation
who wants to take this uh yes so
maybe first how do you mix the cell
suspension so
i would recommend to simply pipe it up
and down to mix the cells
because um shaking the reservoir always
uh has the risk that you have splashes
and you don't want to have that under
the bench
so when you resuspend so when you pipe
it up and down
what what a lot of people do
is they simply overdo it so pipetting up
and down
maybe three to four times is completely
sufficient um
uh to mix the cells and you don't have
to do it like 10 times because then you
have the shear forces again that might
stress the cells
and then the question how long does it
take for the cells to sediment that is a
little bit different to
uh difficult to answer because that will
depend on the on the volume and on the
on the cell number in the cell
suspension so um
you can say it maybe takes a few minutes
until you would see it with the naked
eye
if you have a clear reservoir but
um the the the cells already start to
to sink towards the bottom before so i
would
recommend for a 96 well plate resuspend
two to three times every second row that
you are pipetting and then you can be
can be when you are in a good range of
a good mixing um frequency if you are
not sure if that is sufficient
for your cell concentration then you can
um just try it out and and
and count the the number of cells that
you see that in the first row and
compare it
with the number of cells in the in the
last row so
um then you can be sure if the if the
cell number is
um homogeneous over the whole plate
yeah thank you jessica i hope this this
answers this long question here comes an
uh
shorter question that is
dedicated to eric so the question is
are the essays that you have been
showing us before also applicable to
3d culture eric
well primarily these essays have been
designed for 2d culture
the non-lytic assays that are shown such
as the
the ldh glow essay or that real-time
viability essay
they can be used with 3d cultures
we we've used them successfully for 3d
models like
spheroids if it's a lytic assay
such as the cell tita glow assay then of
course the limiting
factor for using them with 3d cultures
is
the the lysis condition because you have
to
achieve a thorough lysis of a spheroid
for example
so you have to make sure that the assay
is achieving a thorough lysis of your
sample with regard to the cell tidal
glow assay we have
a version that is optimized for 3d
called cells header glow 3d
assay here the lysis strength
and the protocol for that assays have
been
optimized but in general every lytic
assay
could be applicable to 3d cultures
you just have to make sure that the the
lysis is thorough
yeah thank you eric i think this uh this
answers the question
um let's go to the next one i have one
that's probably going to jessica's
direction so the question is
our incubator has a fan inside so how
can i protect the cells from vibrations
caused by the fan
well basically um you cannot when you
when you have a
fan inside the incubator um
it cannot be avoided that the fan um is
switched on it is usually
i think it's dependent on which exact
device you have but it's usually
switched on after a door opening so and
also in between when the door is closed
so you cannot avoid that
so depending on where the fan is located
inside the chamber i would just try to
put myself
as far away as possible from the
location of that fan to
to reduce the vibration
as much as possible but when the
incubator
has a fan there is no way to yeah to to
avoid that the cells will be in
infected and affected in some way by
this vibration
yeah thank you very much i think it's
also important to
to monitor yourselves and see if there's
any effect on the location inside the
incubator if you
if you see any differences there
so the next question um that we have is
do the substances you use in the
real-time assays have any toxic effect
on the cells i've heard that a lot
before also in
form and i think this one goes to eric
yeah i think so too um no they don't not
well at least for for the time frame
that we've tested circles 72 hours
we didn't see any toxic effect the way
we check for this is that we
pre-incubated cells for that given time
frame with the assay reagents and we
then use these cells in a
subsequent assay and
compare these ic50 values that we for
example determined within
toxic compound with non-pre-treated
cells
and we did not see any difference
so at least for that time frame it's not
toxic but i'm pretty sure you could
expand that also for
you could incubate yourself also for
longer time frames but
that's the time window we tested because
we think the 72 hours
is also a time window that you would
usually run an essay
for because if you think of how many
cells you would have after three days
it's probably not applicable to to run
an assay longer than 72 hours
yeah and i think if you do um you just
use the same control as you do to be
sure that there are
no toxic effects if you use um run an
essay
longer than 72 um 17 to all right
yeah so let's go to the next question we
have a lot of questions still coming in
um so
let's choose this one here how to detect
eukaryotic
contamination how to avoid it is a
question from laurent
wants to take this one jessica yes um
well it's it's difficult to to
to detect eukaryotic contamination just
by looking at the cells because
um as i mentioned unless the cell
morphology
of the two cross-contaminated cell lines
is not drastically different
um you you can can hardly
see that there's a a cell line
contaminating um
your cell so um whenever the cells
suddenly
look different than you're used to then
i would
um would pay attention but what you can
actually do
to really detect the eukaryotic
contamination
is an str analysis so scr stands for
short tandem repeats and this is the
gold standard method
to detect cross-contamination or to
authenticate
a cell line and the question how to
avoid
you carry contamination there's a few
things
to um yeah that way you can can pay
attention to so one would be
to have separate um media bottles for
each cell and
and only work with one cell line at a
time
in the biosafety cabinet
[Music]
disinfect the the workspace in between
switching the cell lines and never use
any reagents or any um
media bottles aliquots or whatever for
two different
um for two different cell lines so keep
it as separate as possible
yeah jessica thank you very much i think
we're a little bit over time but there
are so many questions and we
think you're still still out there we
carry on for
maybe another two minutes so another
question that we have
is um probably going to eric's direction
the question is can i only perform
real-time measurements if my reader
instruments
is equipped with an atmospheric control
eric
no it is also possible if you don't have
an ac
the the minimal requirement is really
that you have a heating function
in order to maintain that constant
temperature
if you do not have a co2 supply you what
you need to do is you have to switch
your cell culture medium from a
bicarbonate buffer to a co2
independent medium these media use a
different buffer usually that's
heaps because otherwise your your ph
of the medium will simply or increase
over time so it will become
basic or turn pink as i mentioned before
yeah so thank you eric i think
this line next question will be the last
question for today um
we are um we will answer all of your
questions
afterwards and email you but now let's
go to the last question that is coming
from
petra from the university of ghent and
the question is
how do you defrost cells from -80 by
applying heat shock for a few seconds
or with warm medium you want to take
this one
um yes thank you for that question so
first of all
you should never um store
cells for a long time or store
eukaryotic cells for a long time at
minus 80. so
um the the long-term storage temperature
for eukaryotic cells should always be
um at least minus 120 150
minus 80 should not be should not be
used for longer than a few days
so i would i would recommend to to
to saw the cells as quickly as possible
because
you usually use a cryoprotectant when
you freeze the cells
most commonly as dmso and this is
cytotoxic
when the when in non-frozen state so
you want to make sure that you get rid
of the dmso or deluded as soon as
possible
so you can
if you do a heat shock you of course
have to
have to check whether this heat shock
harms the cell
so just do a viability
check maybe 48 hours after thawing
and yeah so i would just dilute the
cells with pre-warmed medium
and then it depends a little bit on the
cell type you're working with
you can either centrifuge the cells
right after thawing
to get rid of the dmso immediately or
you can
dilute the uh the cells
and um um uh changed the medium the next
day so for some
some cell lines are more sensitive to
even low concentration of the mso
and some are more sensitive to the
centrifugation step so if you don't know
what is the method of choice for your
cell line
i would simply compare both methods
and then see how the cells behave
yeah thank you jessica thank you also
eric for answering these questions
this was um quite a fast right through
the
q and a session so we have received over
let's
have a look over 200 questions that will
all be answered so thank you again
jessica
and eric do you have any final comments
for our audience
um thank you all for joining our webinar
today and
um yeah we as as christian said we will
follow up
any questions via email and within the
next days so
yeah goodbye from my side and take care
yeah also i would like to thank you for
joining the webinar
um if you have any questions
popping up later on you can also contact
us
us via email yeah stay healthy and thank
you
so before we go i would like to thank
you all for joining us today and for
your interesting questions
um as we said questions where we did not
have the time
for today and those that were submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the end of the registration
i would like to thank jessica and eric
again for their time today and for
their brilliant presentation for sharing
their experience
we would also like to thank chrissy
jewell and the lab roots team for
supporting us today
and i'd like to make sure that you know
that this webcast can be viewed on
demand
and lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay and we
encourage you all to share this email
with your colleagues who may have missed
the
webinar today keep in mind to have a
look at the inside cell culture
newsletter to stay updated on all
upcoming cell culture webinar
so we say goodbye from hamburg have a
nice day and most importantly
stay happy stay healthy and help to
protect others
as well bye bye
you